destructuring assignment take values
from arrays or properties from objects
and set them
as local variables it's a technique that
can make your javascript code more
concise and readable
imagine you have an array and you want
to assign some of its values to local
variables
one option is to assign each variable by
referencing its index in the array
that works fine but it's not very
elegant with destructuring we can do the
same thing with a single line of code
by using brackets after const we can
assign a variable name
to each index in the array the position
of the variable name
matches the values index in the array
the syntax may look familiar to you if
you've ever used react which relies on
destructuring for the used state hook
when working with arrays you may want to
emit a variable which you can do by
adding a comma without a variable name
to skip that index
in other cases you might want to name
the first couple variables
then put the remainder in their own
array that can be achieved by putting
three dots in front of the variable name
you might also want to set a default
value in case the value in the array is
undefined use the equal sign to provide
the fallback value
in addition to arrays destructuring also
applies to objects
notice how we're duplicating the
object's property name as a variable
with dot notation
by putting braces after const you can
reference property names which will
automatically become local variables
which is much cleaner than referencing
them line by line with dot notation
and just like arrays you can use the
equal sign to set a default value
but in some cases you may want to use a
different name than what's provided on
the object itself
adding a colon after the property name
allows you to rename it which is
especially useful when dealing with name
collisions or when working with objects
that use property names that are not
valid variable names
in addition to renaming you can also use
a colon to access
nested properties or in other words set
a variable from an object within an
object
in addition to destructuring top level
variables you can also use the syntax in
for loops
which is awesome when you have an array
of objects when working with functions
you can destructure arrays and objects
passed as arguments
providing yet another way to obliterate
unnecessary lines of javascript from
your code base
this has been destructuring assignment
in javascript in 100 seconds
make sure to hit the like button it
really helps out these short videos
thanks for watching and if you want to
learn more hang out for a minute while
we go over a few more advanced tricks
that you may not know about
one thing that array destructuring
enables is variable swapping without the
need for an intermediate variable it
doesn't come up often in javascript but
it is a useful thing to know for
computer science in general
normally to swap two variables you need
a temporary variable because once the
first variable is reassigned you lose
its value
but with a radius structuring we have
the syntax available to perform a swap
without the need for the intermediate
variable
use destructuring to reassign the values
by putting the original two
in an array but in reverse order you'll
probably almost never do that but you
might be able to use it to impress
someone on a technical interview someday
the other thing i wanted to show you is
that destructuring can also be used with
regular expressions
when you run the match function on a
string it returns an array of results
you can then easily provide descriptive
variable names for the regular
expression matches
that's cool but i have one last thing to
mention imagine you want to destructure
an object
but you don't know the property name
until runtime you can use computed
properties in destructuring
just like you can with object literals
by wrapping a property name in brackets
it now takes a variable as its value
instead of a static name
in other words it's computed at runtime
which you can then follow with a colon
to provide it with a static variable
name to use in your code and that's
pretty much everything i know about
destructuring